c'est l'un des plus grands joueurs de
tous les temps voici l'histoire de John
alumu la légende All Black mort à
seulement 40 ans c'est celui qui a fait
exploser le rugby aux yeux du monde
pour ses adversaires c'était un
véritable cauchemar je pense qu'on n'a
jamais vu une chose pareille sur un
terrain de rugby
[Musique]
salut c'est Hugo cette semaine coupe du
monde de rugby oblige j'avais envie de
vous parler de la légende du ballon
ovale John a le mot rapide puissant
technique c'était le joueur parfait il a
marqué le monde du sport de son
empreinte et ses adversaires aussi
nous sommes au mois de juin 1995 lors de
la Coupe du monde de rugby en Afrique du
Sud le public découvre alors un jeune
joueur hors du commun Jonah Lomu un
mètre 96 116 kg capable de courir le
100m en moins de 11 secondes et encore
inconnu lors des premiers matchs de
poule il y avait l'Irlande et le paie
des gars il a marché dessus dès la
deuxième minute de la demi-finale qui
oppose la Nouvelle-Zélande à
l'Angleterre le jeune ailier All Blacks
inscrit un essai d'anthologie où il
écrase littéralement my cat avant
d'aplatir dans l'embut adverse c'était
absolument remarquable des Anglais et
n'avaient aucune réponse à ce ce monstre
que c'était ce jour-là
Jonah le mot inscrit 4 essais il entre
dans la légende des propulse le rugby
dans une autre dimension c'est lui qui a
précipité le rugby dans le monde moderne
c'est tout de suite après que le rugby
est passé professionnel pour la première
fois de son histoire le rugby à la
Nouvelle-Zélande les deux en grandit
ensemble c'est quelque chose
d'identitaire dans l'histoire de la
Nouvelle-Zélande la première fois que
les All Blacks sont venus jouer en
Europe en 1904-1905 ils ont battu tout
le monde dans tout d'un coup on en
parlait en Europe en France en
Angleterre un Grande-Bretagne l'identité
de la nation en partie c'est créer
autour de ça journal est né en 1975 dans
la banlieue de clan de la capital
économique de la Nouvelle-Zélande ses
parents sont originaires de plusieurs
îles polynésiennes Samoa Tonga et Wallis
à cette époque la France mène des essais
nucléaires dans le Pacifique une immense
lueur dégageant autant d'énergie que 2
millions de tonnes de TNT et puis les
normes champignons qui est selon les
techniciens parfaitement inoffensifs sa
mère est venue en Nouvelle-Zélande
pendant que sa grossesse parce qu'elle
avait peur des effets des essais
nucléaires français dans le victime de
mauvais traitements de la part d'un père
violent le jeune Jona grandit dans les
quartiers sud de clan en proie aux
guerres de gang il habitait dans un
quartier très pauvre d'Auckland où il
subissaient les gangs des gants
polynésiens les temps géants contre les
Samoa quand les Maoris qui les entré
dans le giron du rugby néo-zélandais à
travers le sport scolaire
dans le 125 lycée et envoyé sur le
tableau le champion de l'année pendant
plusieurs années le champion de tous les
sports c'était Jonah lomo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
commence à faire parler ses qualités
athlétiques exceptionnelles sa puissance
sa technique mais surtout sa vitesse
en 1994 il remporte le tournoi de Hong
Kong de rugby à 7 l'épreuve phare de la
discipline quelques mois plus tard il
cessait au rugby à 15 et devient le plus
jeune joueur à porter le maillot des All
Blacks positionné à l'aile il joue son
premier match contre la France lors de
la tournée de préparation pour la Coupe
du Monde il en profite pour s'adresser
au président français au sujet des
essais nucléaires dans le Pacifique
lors de la finale de la Coupe du Monde
1995 les All Blacks ultra favoris
affronte les Springbox sur leur terrain
l'Afrique du Sud qui sort de l'apartheid
participe au mondial pour la première
fois de son histoire
sud-africaine met tout en oeuvre pour
laisser le moins d'espace possible à
Jonah Lomu la Nouvelle-Zélande finit par
s'incliner tous les blacks qui ont joué
ce jour-là savent que quelque part même
s'ils ont le regret de ne pas avoir
gagné la finale ils ont le bonheur
d'avoir contribué à l'histoire de
l'Afrique du Sud
deux jours avant la finale l'équipe
néo-zélandaise est décimée par une vague
d'intoxication alimentaire l'ex garde du
corps de Nelson Mandela alors président
de l'Afrique du Sud affirmera des années
plus tard que les All Blacks ont été
empoisonnées
il est surnommé Big Man ou encore
l'autobus
[Musique]
lors de la Coupe du Monde 1999 la
Nouvelle-Zélande qui domine la scène
mondiale depuis 4 ans affronte la France
en demi-finale dans l'enceinte mythique
de tweetenham cela paraît impossible que
les Français puissent vous battre
les Français sont totalement
imprévisibles s'ils sont dans un mauvais
jour c'est clair il joue mal mais dans
un bonjour
en essayant de le plaquer l'étaler ce
deuxième essai en début de deuxième
période et là on pensait que les Blacks
avaient gagné qui étaient en finale
quelques minutes plus tard le 15 de
France reprend des couleurs et arrache
la victoire en inscrivant 33 points
d'affilée en moins d'une demi-heure
ne sera jamais sacré champion du monde
en dehors du terrain Jonah Lomu doit
faire face à de graves problèmes de
santé des 1996 les médecins lui
diagnostiquent un syndrome néphrotique
une insuffisance rénale qui nécessite
une greffe il ne pouvait pas s'entraîner
comme les autres la récupération était
beaucoup plus lente ça devenait de plus
en plus difficile même en 96 avant que
le grand public ne le sache Jonah Lomu
est placé sous dialyse 2 à 3 fois par
semaine il doit être hospitalisé pendant
plusieurs heures la star des All Blacks
n'est pas en mesure de s'aligner pour la
Coupe du Monde 2003
en 2004 Jonah Lomu bénéficie d'une
transplantation rénale et l'année
suivante il retrouve le chemin des
terrains
pour revenir ils sentaient que c'était
son destin il voulait pas renoncer
[Musique]
grâce à la greffe sa santé s'améliore
mais la star des All Blacks peine à
retrouver son plus haut niveau en 2007
il annonce la fin de sa carrière mais
deux ans plus tard il fait un retour
surprise en France avec le club de
Marseille Vitrolles en Fédérale une
cinquième division c'était quand même
pas le Jonah qu'on a connu parce qu'il
était beaucoup plus lourd il avait pas
la même vitesse il n'avait plus la
l'accélération foudroyante qu'il a eu au
début de sa carrière malgré sa maladie
Jonah le mou continue de se lancer des
défis il perd 30 kilos et cessé au
culturisme il tente même une
reconversion en boxe anglaise
c'est un combat pour la vie je sais ce
qu'est la vie quand on a perdu la santé
il faut se battre pour s'en sortir
cesse de fonctionner il doit de nouveau
être hospitalisé plusieurs fois par
semaine dans l'attente d'un donneur
quelques mois avant sa disparition Jonah
Lomu se rend en Angleterre pour la Coupe
du monde dans les rues de Londres il
prend part aux traditionnels aka une
danse guérilla maori destinée à
impressionner l'adversaire
[Applaudissements]
18 novembre 2015 Jonah Lomu meurt d'une
crise cardiaque à son domicile deckland
à seulement 40 ans
[Applaudissements]
dans l'enceinte de l'Eden Park deckland
le temple des All Blacks ses proches
soutenus par ses anciens coéquipiers lui
rendent un dernier hommage
[Applaudissements]
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu n'hésitez
pas à dire ce que vous en avez pensé en
commentaire et à vous abonner à la
chaîne brut et si vous voulez regarder
d'autres vidéos du même style vous avez
le lien de la playlist dans la
description en dessous à très vite